hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his essay
concrete approaches to investigating the
ontological mystery Gabrielle Marcel
will pause for a moment early on in that
and suggest to us several mistaken
attitudes or approaches or perspectives
not only found in philosophy but
particularly in that discipline but but
in life and culture more generally that
bar the way to even considering whether
this is a real issue or question and
they bar the way to what Marcel is going
to call mystery to jump ahead a little
bit each of them treats it either as a
problem or a non problem and when I say
it what are we talking about
Marcel speaks of ontological need in
France exigence
and that could be translated as need or
also as demand it gets translated in the
English text sometimes as need and
sometimes as exigency just a cognate of
it and what we're talking about is
something within us within the beings
that we are that demands or calls to or
hankers after or desires being and you
might say well why would it do that
I mean beings are beings that's it well
the concept of being or the notion of
being is one of the most difficult and
tricky and slippery ones in Western
metaphysics Marcel says I'm not going to
try to define being for you here all
those who give us a characterization but
he will tell us that there's there's
something more than just a mere being
you might say that we have we need
something greater than that we desire
something more and he expresses this by
saying this need is telling us that
there there must be here we go if we
force ourselves to translate this
exigency without modifying it we will be
led to saying something like this there
must be or must have been being
everything cannot be finally reduced to
the interplay of successive and
inconsistent appearances this word
inconsistent he says is essential or
Shakespeare is phrased it to a tale told
by an idiot so he's not just talking
about being as existence or being there
he's talking about you might call it the
intensity of being or if you want to use
another term meaningfulness and he says
this is something that we human beings
need and it can't just be something
purely subjective something purely in
our head when he characterizes being in
this this section he says I'll just
propose this approach being is what
resists or what would be what would
withstand an exhaustive analysis of the
data of experience it would try to
reduce them progressively to elements
increasingly devoid of any intrinsic
value or significance and so being is
you might say not just the residue
that's left after we carry out analyses
being is what holds all of those things
together and provides them with a a
meaning provides them with something
going beyond their mere component parts
he is not unique in
viewing being in this way so he says
that there's several mistaken attitudes
that are going to interfere with this
this need so he goes on he says here we
go a philosophy that refuses to give
serious consideration to this
ontological exigency is indeed possible
it's a possibility for us it's a
possibility for philosophers at any
given time so there's no like perfect
period like say the Middle Ages in which
they discovered the analogy of being
from our cell that's not actually going
to cut it he's not saying we need to
look back to say Thomas Aquinas or
anything like that which by the way as a
Catholic philosopher would be a common
thing to do at the time that he's
writing he he puts that path behind us
he says at any given point it's possible
of a philosophy that denies that rejects
that pushes away this question he also
thinks that this is particularly endemic
in modern times and he also tells us too
that you know the ontological need can
only be reduced to silence by an
arbitrary dictatorial act that mutilate
spiritual life and it's very root so
there are consequences to not
acknowledging the ontological need and
here's the important part going back to
the it's always a possibility for
philosophy it's not just a possibility
for philosophy it's a possibility for
any one of us he says such an act is
always possible our conditions of
existence are such that we can really
believe we've accomplished it and this
is something that we must not forget
this is a genuine possibility precisely
because we do have in some way this
tenuous contact to something more
something greater that involves us as
subjects but also involves the world
that that meets us in the Nexus of our
body that Marcel considers so important
but isn't reducible to the corporeal all
of this affords us the possibility
of engaging in a kind of reflection what
Marcel will often call primary
reflection as opposed to secondary
reflection which takes itself into
account that ends up closing off some of
our deeper possibilities so he talks
about a first attitude the first
mistaken attitude he says is one of
consistently reserving judgment this
would be the attitude of agnosticism in
all of its forms so we just don't know
we're not gonna ever commit ourselves to
anything you could call it agnosticism
you could call it a certain kind of
skepticism you could call it by other
names as well being prudent holding back
and he says that this first attitude has
an exclusively negative import and he
suggests that it corresponds to a
certain intellectual politics the
question will not be asked what question
the question of being what is being and
you know the further questions how my
being and also connected to being and
what am i right those are not going to
be asked we take some answers for
granted and then we just go on from
there and we Vince the sort of
skepticism towards any other seeking of
the answer we might do it on the basis
of we don't have enough time for this or
this is not what serious people spend
their spare energy on you know there's
all sorts of possibilities for doing
this Marcel doesn't spend a lot of
discussion on that instead he talks
about a second attitude that he calls
bolder and more coherent and this one is
very common in not only his time but
also in our time and that had been
common for several centuries before him
because it has to do with modernity
itself he says the other bolder and more
coherent would see the ontological
exigency as a remnant of an outdated
dogmatism that idealist critique has
discredited now we don't
necessarily need to worry about idealist
critique because there's all sorts of
other things that could substitute for
that critique particularly in our own
presence we we could say that other
forms of philosophical analysis or even
the you know sort of pared down versions
of philosophy that that we tend to teach
today would rule this out and say oh no
back in the old days people like
Aristotle we're concerned about this but
we don't have to be worried about that
sort of thing now that's just something
you know of the past or if it is around
we'll relegate it to literature or the
you know the supernatural whatever that
happens to be or or you know pick
whatever you like there's a dismissive
attitude involved in there a know-it-all
ism that is based on some sort of
philosophical system so he says this
second attitude pretends to be based on
a positive theory of knowledge and he
says I'm not going to give a detailed
critique I will just mention a few
things he says so there's really two key
things one is he identifies what it
takes to be a tendency or set of
tendencies involved in these and here he
might seem a little inconsistent if you
think about what these terms mean he
talks about an unconscious relativism or
monism and if you think about what
monism means it's the you know
metaphysical assertion that everything
is really one thing everything is really
all the same it's just different ways of
putting it together we can have this
fromthe always assertion that everything
is water all the way to Spinoza's notion
that there's substance and all we are
really modes of substance put together
in certain ways down to you know certain
scientific materialists of his time in
our own time who think that everything
is just you know not even atoms but
particles put together in certain ways
mixed together with energy and bound
together by certain you know primary
forces and then we build everything up
on
basis what about relativism relativism
is the notion that well everything is
basically a matter of perspective and I
don't think that mark Marcel is
particularly concerned about moral
relativism here I think he's more
signaling something of a perspective
ilysm that says there really is nothing
behind the appearances the appearances
and the appearances for us are all that
we get and they vary from person to
person to person imagine sort of like a
berkeley and universe but take God out
of the picture so that you know to be is
to be perceived and there's nothing
assuring a constancy to it so he says
that a lot of times these attitudes
really boiled down into that and those
would block the way to saying that
there's anything like being in the sense
that he means it he also says that they
have a number of different features they
tend to deny the transcendent and try to
reduce it to caricatures that
misrepresent it's essential
characteristics anything that would be
beyond it it says put in my terms or
shut the hell up because you know unless
you're expressing it in terms of you
know back in the old days German
idealism in its language or analytic
philosophy when it's focusing on
language unless you can express it in
terms of language games or pick whatever
you want now
you know possible world semantics or you
know the latest Continental critique
jargony rich in many ways pick pick
anything you like it's the same attitude
fit it into my boxes or it doesn't exist
and that denies any possibility for the
transcendent he also says that it
ignores the personal in all of its forms
it it excludes the personal the personal
can't really matter even those who today
would say oh the personal is is public
or the personal is political they don't
mean the personal in the same respect
that we do they often mean the personal
blown up into something like you know a
public facing image which is not the
same thing as the individual human being
he says it also ignores the tragic and
this is something quite important and
you might expand this further and say it
even ignores the dramatic in all of its
sense and that's important for Marcel a
philosophy that cannot take account of
our dramatic situation as human actors
is deficient in many respects that is
one main way that we experience what
he's calling this need for being I do
also want to mention his discussion here
of the Cartesian coach Ito he he brings
this up because he says when we start
reflecting on this on the ontological
need there's a paradox here to formulate
this engages me in a labyrinth of
problems does being exist what is being
but I can't reflect on these without a
new abyss opening up beneath my feet and
what is that abyss my questioning myself
what am i what kind of being am i what
what being do I have and he says surely
I who articulate this problem I should
be able to remain outside of it whether
this be before beyond the problem and he
says actually no and this is why the
Cartesian coach Ito as brilliant as it
is does not provide us with the
grounding that we need in order to get
get beyond this because it's not a
matter of getting beyond it's not a
matter of solving a problem so he says
despite what Descartes might have
thought if he gives us an indubitable
the sole certainty which it provides
concerns only the epistemological
subject as the organ of objective
cognition Marcel says it does guard the
threshold of validity there is something
important about the I am or the I exist
but there's more to me and there's more
to me in relation to being as a being
among beings and a being in relation to
being so he says one of the errors
that's involved here is
taking the knowing subject as the human
being arbitrarily separating the
question am i from the ontological
problem taken as a holy sis neither of
these can be approached in isolation
they can only be approached jointly and
simultaneously and that goes against the
Cartesian method of breaking everything
down into its subproblems and solving
each of them in turn which is great for
some things but doesn't work for what
Marcel is talking about here he also
says that the Cartesian position is
inseparable from a dualism that he
rejects without hesitation to pose the
ontological problem is to inquire about
the totality of being and about myself
as a totality so he's rejecting any sort
of dualism whether it be a body and mind
whether it be of self and world or self
and other these are not going to work
for him and so he suggests also that
that vitalism of different sorts is not
going to be the way through here as well
and to bring this sort of two to a close
the fundamental problem as Marcel sees
it is treating being itself as if it's a
problem and now I'm using the word
problem here in in a sort of ironic way
for Marcel there's going to be a vital
distinction between a problem which is
something that can be solved with some
sort of technique some sort of
discipline and can be considered apart
from the subjects involvement in it and
a mystery which is in some respects a
meta problem a problem at a
problematized problem if you like but
one that actually brings in the person
who is examining it within the scope of
the inquiry and the ontological need or
demand or exigency is only going to be
able to be understood from a perspective
that views
as a mystery rather than a problem and
all of these mistaken approaches that
we've looked at treat it as a problem
you